hello and welcome to this video playing
Alcoa layer corner well 19 out of 20 to
whisper score it's high maybe I can test
the maracas see all of it against him
but didn't seem to be interested now h5
is like I had that I recently had a game
when I had the white pieces in the Sun
in the setup and I asked myself what
would I do with black plates h5 them and
I want I should participate and I think
it's not that not that bad to push the H
porn here with black their white knight
on d4 mmm yeah it's not really in a
position to prevent this and yeah this
is not that terrible I think maybe see
5c 5 by white that could be an option
okay well I can take now that looks
wrong anyway what club koinonia looks
unstable okay take first yeah Queen 85
is asking a very inconvenient question
usually you would answer tweenage five
with might be three but not with the
bishop 1g5 yeah it's a bit awkward or
what what's this move now the Queen d2
doesn't work and I takes d4 winning a
piece
9f three letters that that's really not
very inspiring yeah I can even go light
h7 that somewhat okay I'm we should age
45 winter piece and if he goes back then
queen age five just playing for caveman
style but okay I mean I'm probably still
too much orders to strategist like to
play this okay so 95 might be on and
then I have 94 maybe ok t6 the ideas
Bishop g4 with the temple on the g5
Bishop a 95 maybe 94 that's probably
certain idea for wide 925 you are not
getting checkmated quickly
try that device may be but if i apply
this one probably probably be three then
that's not bad why does that work
just winning a pawn yeah I think
pawn takes Queen takes just a pawn
now my bishops I extremely strong
difficult center to keep material him so
and he wants to go night to this form I
probably should keep the bishop here I
take it does look c7 so just put the
night back p 2 is still on the file
what really it is pretty bad to talk to
how to learn yeah not lose the second
point yeah ok so I think that yeah I
know that h5 look strange it was just
like I had this during a game and I was
thinking okay what what am i doing if he
plays that yeah I was why I had it yeah
and I wasn't I wasn't exactly sure what
what I would do and the engine the
engine and want to go h3 now h3 is oil
intending this thing one that looks a
little bit wrong I think h3 makes sense
castles age floor I don't know yeah i
was already reasonably happy should be
five yeah yeah I'm fine maybe this is an
idea take dig what the computer give
taking this night h2 what what is that
where's the dichroic that's crazy I can
I mean here I was really happy that must
be is mostly good for white f or black
cap sorry yeah it's really really
annoying and that that will to porn for
me and yeah well he's free that night eh
heaven that's also very awkward
I don't know an earlier designs but came
I mean he has a pretty awful history
against me like losing almost every game
so 18 wins one loss ok guys thanks for
watching